beards braids and blood transforming
into a viking isn't easy except for one
actress who was pretty much born for the
part find out who and so much more right
here
australian actor sam corlett portrays
the legendary explorer leif eriksen the
norseman whose thoughts were being the
first european to have set foot in north
america centuries before christopher
columbus in a promotional packet
provided to the press netflix describes
the ericsson of vikings valhalla saying
he's a greenlander raised on the outer
fringes of the known world who comes
from a tightly knit family steeped in
pagan beliefs it goes on to say that
although leif is an intrepid sailor and
physically tough he is also thoughtful
and often quiet and apparently
relatively new to the viking world which
is in the quote throes of violent change
when corlett was a teenager he actually
watched the original vikings with his
father so it's fitting that he would go
on to star in its spin-off the real-life
collette still has the long hair and
facial hair of his viking counterparts
but keeps it much more neatly trimmed
and styled than eriksen on set collette
who is vegan was costumed in vegan
leather armor to honor his personal
convictions
this is another distinct difference
between the actor and the character
he'll be portraying
one of the most beloved characters on
vikings was a shield maiden lagether
played by catherine winick so viewers
are likely eager to see another female
viking warrior rise up in the valhalla
character freydis eric stutter netflix's
description for freydis reads fiery and
headstrong freydis is a staunch believer
in the old gods and the fierce pagan
like her brother leif she reaches
katagat as an outsider but becomes an
inspiration to those of the old ways
freydis will be portrayed by swedish
model frieda gustafsson who has had an
impressive career walking in shows for
some of the world's most celebrated
designers as one might expect of someone
with gustofsten's professional
background her real-life look is much
more polished than the armored and
intricately braided freitas in what
feels like a cosmic coincidence
gustafsson's real-life nickname is also
freydis and her actual father and
brother are also named eric and leif
just like those of her character in the
show
vikings viewers will remember king
harold played by peter franzen who
appeared in season 4 through 6 of the
series as a leader determined to be
crowned king of all norway vikings
alhalla will follow one of his
descendants harold siegertsen who
carries the same ambition as his
ancestor his netflix bio reads born into
viking nobility herald is one of the
last viking berserkers and the prince of
norway intent on becoming king of norway
charismatic ambitious and handsome he is
able to unite both christian and pagan
vikings
keep an eye on him
harold would be portrayed by english
actor leo suter who bears very little
resemblance to his viking character
while harold sports the typical viking
look of a full beard and long hair
suitor typically tends to prefer going
clean-shaven and keeping his hair
cropped fairly short
some actors need to undergo greater
transformations than others for their
roles and vikings valhalla and actor
bradley friegard may be one of the least
altered for his role as king knut the
king of denmark the netflix press
materials describe knut saying a wise
savvy and ruthless viking leader he
keeps his friends close and his enemies
closer canoes ambitions will mould the
course of history in the 11th century
and make him a defining figure of the
viking age in real life welsh actor
fregaard doesn't look too remarkably
different from his character
both have dark hair and full beards
although knuts keeps his black hair long
and tightly pulled back while free guard
wears has cut shorts and allows some of
the natural grey to peek through
freegard also keeps his beard trimmed to
a much shorter length than canutes
canute's family play a central role in
vikings valhalla with his wife and
father also vying for power as knut
works to make sure denmark remains on
top of the political hierarchy
it wouldn't be a viking story without
feuding siblings and valhalla promises
that in space icelandic actor johannes
hokar johannesson portrays olaf
haraldson sigurdsson's older
half-brother and prince of norway olaf
is first in line for the norwegian
throne which we imagine will be a point
of contention between him and harold
olaf's netflix bio reads ambitious
unforgiving and a physical force to be
reckoned with olaf is also an extremely
devout christian viking
vikings viewers remember that the former
priest athelstan was the first
practicing christian to live among the
vikings although the conflict between
his beliefs and those of his viking
neighbors ultimately led to his death it
will be interesting to see how those
dynamics have shifted over a century
later in real life johannesson has kept
the long full beard of his character but
not his long hair preferring instead a
style that is cut closed on the sides
and slightly longer on top in addition
to being one of the main cast members of
vikings valhalla johannes hoga
johannesson is also an accomplished chef
the netflix press kit mentions that he
was frequently known to bring in
homemade baked goods for the stunt crew
during rehearsals
of the viking leader yao haken netflix's
press packet reads a great warrior and
tolerant leader harken rules katagat
with a steady hand though pagan she has
managed to keep katagata city open to
all faiths in a challenging time she
will become a powerful mentor to freydis
who is drawn to her wisdom of course we
know from watching ragnar's struggles
and vikings just how difficult it can be
to maintain peace between people of
different faiths in katagat so it will
be interesting to see how yall harken
manages to pull that off if such a thing
is even possible i want to be reunited
with my christian friend jalhakam will
be played by danish swedish singer
caroline henderson who is known
primarily for her more recent jazz
albums after previously singing mostly
pop y'all harkin is one of very few
viking women we've seen in promotional
materials who seems to wear her hair
loose more often than not so her normal
appearance is not quite as drastic of a
shift from her viking look as some of
her castmates
valhalla will feature the family of one
of alfred king of wessex's descendants
king eighth or red the second and a thor
red's wife emma of normandy this is what
the netflix press packet has to say of
emma the young ambitious emma of
normandy is from the norman court in
france and the viking blood she is now
married to king aethal red ii the
current king of england politically
astute and one of the wealthiest women
in europe queen emma is a sharp and
capable leader emma seems to follow in a
long tradition of shrewd queens on
vikings and is portrayed by german actor
and model laura berlin on valhalla
emma's hair is a dark brown but in real
life berlin's hair color has run the
full spectrum of colors from dark to
light and even a vibrant purple at one
point berlin has worked as a model since
she was a teenager making her no
stranger to the intricate costumes she
needs to wear as emma
described in netflix's press materials
for vikings valhalla as quote the
ultimate survivor david oaks's character
the earl of godwin serves as chief
counselor to the king of england 8th or
red ii of godwin's character the
description reads godwin was born on the
political fringes and is haunted by his
late father's mistakes cunning and savvy
he knows how to make powerful allies
godwin's portrayal is english actor
david oakes who is no stranger to
historical dramas thanks his work on
shows such as the borgias the white
queen and victoria
vikings introduced us to the complicated
world of english royal succession and
viking salhallah continues that theme
with prince edmond played by english
actor louis davidson its official
netflix bio reads king aethor red the
second son with his first deceased wife
and now emma of normandy's stepson
edmund is first in line to inherit the
english throne edmund is nervous to lead
but will play a vital role in deciding
england's future
davidson is still a relative newcomer to
the world of television only appearing
in a few roles before landing his part
on vikings valhalla in real life
davidson's hair is much lighter than
edmund's dark color and although it is
still not long he tends to wear it much
more loosely than edmund's severe style
season 4 of vikings introduced us to
aethelredd the legitimate son of king
aethelwolf and his wife judith
unfortunately for 8th or red judith
likes a younger son moore and poisoned a
thor red rather than allowing him to
assume the throne vikings valhalla picks
up a few generations down this
dysfunctional family lineage with
alfred's descendant aethelred the second
now on the english throne portraying
alford ii on vikings valhalla is veteran
irish actor bosco hogan he previously
appeared in season 5 of the original
vikings series as a lord abbott and the
lindisfarne monastery in the episode
full moon hogan's look for valhalla
won't be tremendously different from his
real life appearance with the addition
only of a trim grey beard and of course
a royal wardrobe
it wouldn't be a viking show without
some religious extremism and in valhalla
it seems that box will be checked by yal
khare played by danish actor asbion
nissen his netflix bio reads a
mysterious and chilling figure yalkare
is a murderous christian zelda who
presents a real threat to the old pagan
ways it sounds almost as though yalcare
will act as a kind of reverse spiritual
successor to floki played by gustav
skarsgard after all he was a devout
vikings character whose spiritual
convictions led him to eventually murder
athelstan in real life nissan still has
the bald head and long thick beard that
yalcare sports in valhalla although it
looks like he takes much better care of
his beard than his viking counterpart
concerning queen alcafeu played by
pollyanna macintosh netflix's press
packet reads she uses her charm and
guile to great effect as she promotes
the interests of her mercy and homeland
and tries to assert herself in her
husband king knuts growing power
structure the scottish actress takes on
the role of the formidable queen alcafeu
with a look on the show seeing her
donning elaborate blonde tresses this is
a big step away from macintosh's look in
real life although the actor has indeed
been blonde before she is currently a
brunette and has recently been keeping
her hair cut extremely short for her
role as jadis and the walking dead and
the walking dead world beyond you'll be
answering to me
the final member of the main vikings
valhalla cast is danish actor soren
pillmark he plays king sven fogbeard who
netflix describes in their press
materials as king canute's father who is
far less diplomatic than his son he will
do whatever it takes to protect his
family's place of power and has no
tolerance for traitors or those who
question his authority
of course when it comes to vikings we
have a feeling that less diplomatic
tends to mean ruthless and violent so it
will be interesting to see how far the
danish king is willing to go in his
quest to hold on to his power in vikings
valhalla pilmark is nearly
unrecognizable as king fen forkbeard
whose greying hair is long and wild
looking as though he's forgotten to comb
it since well ever contrasted to
pilmark's real-life appearance in which
the actor is typically clean-shaven and
short-haired pilmark's role may be one
of the most dramatic transformations
among the cast of vikings valhalla
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more luba videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]